entre las viviendas artesanales de las
comunidades indígenas del delta del
orinoco en venezuela se mueve una
epidemia la del vih/sida rafael pequeño
es enfermero y líder del pueblo de san
francisco de guayos una de las aldeas
donde la cruz roja venezolana detectó al
virus por primera vez en el 2007 él
conoce en detalle cada caso hoy visita a
eduardo un joven que contrajo el virus
cuando tenía 18 años
actualmente tiene 30 ha bajado de peso
presenta diarreas constantes y
afecciones en los huesos eduardo bajo el
shock del dolor dice que está tomando su
tratamiento para controlar el virus pero
que no cuenta con medicinas para los
efectos adversos porque no las hay
lo remedio aquí uno va pal hospital hay
remedio pero ahorita
edificio
por qué
la gobernadora que tuve y ver la
gobernadora bastante difícil que no
manda mucho para que a veces manda seis
meses o si no un año
para llegar a san francisco de guayos se
necesita tiempo disposición contactos y
dinero no es común que estas poblaciones
tan lejanas que habitan en áreas de
difícil acceso estén expuestas al vih
arelis martínez de la congregación de
las hermanas terciarias capuchinas
comenta que la pobreza ha sido la
principal causa
muchos salen del pueblo a buscar insumos
en un basurero ubicado en puerto ordaz a
siete días en curiara y se contagian
siempre es cada tres meses se atendrá en
una bolsa de comida con unos artículos
que son pocos coméis una semana y
el resto del mes y siguientes a pasar
hambre no se sabe cuál fue el primer
caso registrado pero quince años después
el virus siguen guayos y sus poblaciones
aledañas sin control sin supervisión y
sin ayuda se ha dado un
tratamiento del asunto pero no en la
medida que se requiere o sea no ha
habido erradicación del virus en en san
francisco de guayo
aunque en san francisco de guayo se
descubrieron los cinco primeros casos
del virus éste ha tenido un gran impacto
en otras aldeas más pequeñas como la de
yogur
rafael visita este día a algunos de sus
pacientes en joló donde ha habido más
contagios y muertos hace una década se
hicieron pruebas en esta comunidad en
una casa así y en otra no todos los
tests ya dos dieron positivo
y he tratamiento constantemente hijos
billetes de agua y tratamiento también
ya y
freddy de 16 años ha parado su
tratamiento y rafael debe averiguar la
razón la respuesta es que su padre le
ordenó no tomarlo más
al principio con el tratamiento me
sentía bien
pero ahora que volví a dejarlo volví a
recaer me siento mal mi papá me dijo que
ya no fuera a buscar más tratamiento
porque me sentía mejor
este joven se contagió a los 14 años en
un viaje al basurero es un secreto a
voces que algunos indígenas cuando salen
de la comunidad recurren al trabajo
sexual como fuente de ingresos
cuando se sienten mal los habitantes de
yogures prefieren acudir a este chamán
para calmar las dolencias sin embargo la
tragedia también tocó la casa del
curandero
de mis hijos fallecieron dos por la
enfermedad
uno de ellos se llamaba marcelo
y tenía 28 años cuando falleció
evelio de 30 años conoció a su estado de
vih positivo cuando tenía 20 nos muestra
las tumbas de su tío y de su hermano
ambos vivieron por sida tiene miedo de
morir
es lamentable que haya contraído el
virus
deseo seguir sano
y tenéis larga vida pero siento miedo
el vih que se ha encontrado en las
comunidades de los caños del delta son
de un subtipo b y un subtipo c de al
cáncer tan letal que se convierte en la
etapa más avanzada de la enfermedad en
menos de cinco años
el dia vélez monja y enfermera de la
congregación en san francisco de guayos
es quien lleva por escrito el record de
los pacientes con tratamiento son 23 en
total los registrados una cifra distante
de lo que puede ser la realidad
los casos que van llegando al hospital
nosotros le hacemos la prueba de esa
prueba rápida y bueno y le iniciamos el
tratamiento pero entonces son casos que
ya llegan ya muy deteriorados ya la
gente llega mal entonces uno dice este
es un caso positivo eso lo hacen las
hacemos la prueba el preciso
según el informe de monitoreo global de
sida del año 2020 la prevalencia del vih
en la población general es de 0.53 por
ciento y hasta hace unos pocos años en
la etnia warao era de 92 por ciento en
la actualidad no existen datos precisos
de cuántas personas pueden tener la
enfermedad ni cuántos han muerto por el
virus sin mediciones ni controles la
comunidad ha entrado en un ciclo
imposible de detener
hay personas que lo importan y no
quieren aceptar esa realidad y se
entregan para morir
[Música]
los guardas dicen que cuando hay fiestas
se olviden de todos los problemas y los
contagios a falta de jornadas de
detección el contagio de vih sigue
expandiéndose entre los waraos una
delgada línea es la división entre vivir
y morir el virus llegó para quedarse es
el nuevo ciclo de vida de esta comunidad
indígena
[Música]